you raise a very good point because
feminism you know with feminism women
are like oh I can do whatever I want
when I want how I want so like you know
I can hand address myself no one should
judge me for that and I think that's a
little bit too much but it's interesting
because feminists complain the most
about beauty standards but it just seems
like they care the least about them
well
that wouldn't have you just be like well
I don't have to bother because why would
I let a man dictate how I look yeah but
that's not
they'll say oh man whim such high Beauty
stands so hard for women
the beauty standards Instagram
and I could sympathize it's like if we
really cared wouldn't we be more put
together and way less
if I gravy's point I think it's because
there's a lot of activists though and
feminism and they try to improve that
they feel like all women do what they do
for men but some people do things for
themselves yeah but because there's that
lining of doing things for men a lot of
famous feminisms now are like
they don't want to do it just because
they feel like it's doing it for a man
is it even such a bad thing if they were
doing it for men though because like you
get guys you work who work out because
they want they want to look rich for for
women yeah so yeah it wouldn't be that
terrible yeah to be honest yeah it's
like everyone wants to be like you know
where yeah like if you know if you like
someone and you wanna you know wear
something and you think yeah it's not
like no no I'm wearing this just you
know you want to feel good but you also
you know want to be nice for other
people so yeah I think
whose beauty standards are higher men or
women
[Music]
pens
okay I want to make a rule
no it depends
pick one pick one pick one
tell me why
amen have higher beauty standards I
think okay because they see a lot of
women and they now begin to compare make
comparisons between different types of
women and it's like when they see a
particular woman look in a particular
way is they would compare another woman
to the woman that they've seen but you
think that men have higher standards for
women not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have higher
standards for women for women so like
the women have higher beauty standards
to me yes and that's what's making women
feel like they need to comply with these
standards who's picky or men or women
men definitely yeah yeah what what
percent of the time do you think men
swipe right on dating apps
when does what percent yeah what percent
of the time probably 70.
what percent of the time do you think
women swipe right on dating apps
I think about the same do you know what
70 I think women women are more
complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept more than men do I think men are
very like if they've they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 certainly yeah okay what percent of
the time do you think men swipe right on
dating apps
so men swipe right
um 60 to 70 percent of the time where
women what percent of the time do you
think they swipe right oh wait no sorry
I think it's 45 I'm sorry I misspoke
that's it's about 45 to 50. not so many
yeah for men
um what percent of the time do you think
women's Sweat Right much less yeah I'll
say like 10.
I don't know I'm gonna say 70 to 80.
what do you think do you know this you
have to know this stat well it is around
that isn't it is it about 20 five
percent five percent
yeah I was actually I thought the male
one was actually going to be a bit
higher yeah to be honest because because
a lot of guys well not a lot of guys but
guys have sometimes have this strategy
before the algorithm started clamping
down that they would just swipe on
everything and then see what came
through you know it depends what study
you look at yeah but how could you say
that women are that men are pickier if
women only celebrate five percent of the
time do you know why because they're
talking about they're talking about the
top one percent men are they those top
one percent men those Chads they're
really picky but that's all they
bothered about they're not bother about
the other guys who aren't getting a look
in anyway yeah the top five percent of
men ten what what percent of men do you
guys think are sexually active
yeah
not with themselves
it's not that much of a high percentage
I thought I feel like it's lower than
women's isn't it yeah I don't know but I
feel like it's lower than women's yeah
what person man do you think are
sexually active 70 70
40 I'd say about 16. I would want to say
102. but I'm gonna say 60. 60 yeah me
too
Troy do you notice that how many men is
actually yeah active kind of being very
bad manuscript it's it's low it's low
though yeah I'm curious what can you
tell them a little bit about your
experience like coaching men in dating
yeah I mean so I coach guys I mean I I
create content I write but I coach guys
to get
Traction in terms of dating and the
dating Marketplace is very tough out
there now for everybody but you know a
lot of guys they just really don't get a
look in you know and I think there is
this misconception a lot of women think
oh man I just uh you know that it comes
as easily to man as it does to women and
he really doesn't you know because a
woman basically unless she's
irredeemably unattractive for some
reason can pretty much go out and
probably attract somebody that night you
know there's not a problem with guys
that's not necessarily the case unless
they happen to be either you know top
whatever percentile in terms of looks or
they have social status or they're
famous you know so a lot of guys and a
lot of guys sort of who fall below that
find it very very hard to break through
and then when you add on top of that a
sort of a lack of social skills or lack
of confidence a lack of ability uh to
sort of overcome some of the other
difficulties they might have you know
there are guys who are
really really funny you're very tough
and we seem to be coming into this
environment now where that's you know
the rich get richer the poor get poorer
in terms of dating so the guys who are
at the top who are getting traction
they're they're getting more and more
market share if you like and then the
guys at the bottom are getting less and
less and that's why we've got this issue
with guys who are
frustrated and there's you know this
sort of the insult thing online and
everything like that you know um so I
think it's pretty tough out there for
for a lot of average sort of dudes I
think
yeah
um one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year
oh wow
so so in here
[Laughter]
but so it's funny because a lot of girls
like think that men are pickier than
women but it's actually the opposite
women are much pickier than men I mean
think about out of every 10 men how many
are you really attracted to
who is anyone here would you anyone here
say that they're not picky
I'm peeking I'm definitely picky I think
I've become picky over time yeah
so then wanted to say that men have
higher beauty standards they have to
live up to
haven't you heard women say they won't
date short would any of you date a guy
shorter than them
[Laughter]
two inches shorter than you any of you
doing it and I like to wear heels so
it's not going to work yeah yeah exactly
so I think it is tougher for guys I
think looks wise it has got tougher for
guys and I think you know maybe you
could say well we've had it coming
because the guys were sort of like for a
long time
the looks Focus was very much on women
but I think now very much your guys
really you know it's again look for
Instagram dudes with six packs chiseled
you know features all the rest of it and
the way that social media has has worked
and the way that the dating apps has
worked has meant that women are now look
at these apps and they look at all these
like top guys you know top percentile
guys are like oh that guy's super hot
and then the bloke who who doesn't have
those attributes doesn't measure up so
she's thinking well I want I want this
guy at the top so so now guys being
encouraged to level up you know which is
not
all all together a bad thing right
because self-improvement is good for
everybody you know we should all be
doing what we can do to improve
ourselves every day right but at the
same time I think it is it has got
tougher for guys and then in a society
like here like in the UK
there's a lot of guys who are very
thirsty and you know and and they will
they they will drop their standards you
know
yeah yeah
sad how so do you ever teach guys to
like cold approach women yeah absolutely
yeah yeah and what percent of women are
receptive would you say to I mean like
you've been doing this forever right
yeah but someone that hasn't
um it like he has to go through how many
girls to get a number it depends like
the usual caveats it depends where it is
you know there are certain places like
if you're in like Latin America or it's
a lot more people are maybe Italy as
well actually I don't know maybe not but
you know Latin culture is a bit more
like open yeah they play the card like
you know Latin lover yeah but I don't
know I think it's difficult though like
everybody but to want yeah yeah it is
but to answer the question
um you have to be prepared to go through
a lot of rejection you know like if
you're an average guy and you're you're
going to talk to a woman in a coffee
shop or you know a bar or bookstore or
the grocery store whatever it is you
know you're all going to go through
through rejection
um in fact rejection is is the rule and
the exception really is to get is to get
accepted but that's okay you know it's a
question of accepting that being okay
with that being confident and working on
yourself every day in order to be the
best possible man that you can be
um but yeah a lot of rejection for sure
for people
um I was gonna say well at least a man
has options I feel like women we are our
options are very very limited so even if
even if a man's getting rejected at
least he knows okay fine I can find
another woman who is maybe like a woman
that I'm interested in but for a woman
it's very very difficult I feel like the
options for men are very very difficult
you just go outside
it's true but it's like for me it's not
going to be a guy that I I want but
whose fault is that isn't that your own
fault because that's definitely not my
fault I'm not a seller for anybody that
I'm not attracted to or I don't
absolutely agree we need better options
so yeah I think the men needs to level
up as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible